In the beginning, when we did
all this experimental stuff
we did these little booklets,
telling people what we felt,
what art was for us.
–We did in fact two booklets.
–Yes, do we still have that?
“A Day in the Life of
Gilbert and George,”
and “To Be With Art
Is All We Ask.”
I think “Oh Art What Are You?”
was the most important
early one.
Because that was the tryptic.
And we showed it
at Nigel Greenwood’s gallery.
And to our amazement,
it was bought by the most
important museum in the world.
The Museum of Modern Art
in New York.
We felt extraordinarily proud
I remember.
That is still one of the texts
that reads true today,
the search in the world
for whatever truth
we were looking for,
political, or ethnic or the news
and the killing or whatever.
That’s a text on that in a way.
–And I think it is that one.
–What is the culture?
We like it very much
because it feels like
art is a human person.
Like a blond person
walking along
Charring Cross Road.
And he is art,
and we’re trying to approach him.
So that is trying to approach art,
trying to, what do you call,
–touch it.
–Trying to find the truth.
Find the truth, and it's fantastic.
You talk about how art
is taunting you,
that art is this thing,
this third person.
And it is sort of reaching out
and grabbing you,
and you want to possess it
but you don’t know
actually how to acquire it.
I think we did feel very,
lost and lonely at that time.
More than now.
We were extremely innocent
and naïve in many, many ways
at that time.
But it’s worked
quite interestingly
because in some ways,
we were trained.
Many, many years I saw George
I was trained for six years
for sculptures
and all kinds of stuff.
–Highly trained...
–And even George,
but we realized that’s not it.
Art has to be a vision,
a personal vision
of how you see the world,
how does it feel being alive,
and scratching it on the wall,
like what do you call it?
Cave paintings, no?
Everyone always did.
Your text is not sloppy.
It’s very well considered
and thought out.
Can you talk a little bit about
how you came to the process
of writing the text?
All of our writings were done
at the Wimpy Bar
at Liverpool Street.
Because we had no heating,
so in the evenings
we always had a very drawn-out
dinner at the Wimpy Bar.
It was nice and warm in there.
We did the writing there.
Yes, it’s very interesting because
we became the loners.
And we still are.
We are not going into
neighbors houses, no,
we are alone in the world.
And that was those days already
that we felt alone.
We were walking alone
thinking this person that is art.
We still feel
we’re underneath the arches
in that poetic, dreamy way.
That’s still our life.